daniel bédard est propriétaire d'une
maison à chapet au nord du québec autour
de décence je me trompe à 2015 j'ai fait
une demande pour changer de tarifs
biénergie à hydro électrique lors de
l'installation du compteur électrique de
daniel bédard le technicien
d'hydro-québec effectué la même
opération chez annie coulombe
un résidant du même quartier non je
reçois une première facture puis là sur
la première facture j'ai un montant qui
est beaucoup plus élevé que pour ma
tempe coeuve avait historiquement à
puyoo payer sa facture passe de 60 à
plus de 320 $ mensuellement pendant deux
ans monsieur coulombe cherche la cause
du problème
il découvre que le numéro de son
compteur électrique est différent de
celui inscrit sur sa facture
alain coulombe comprend qu'il a payé
l'électricité consommée par daniel
bédard hydro québec réclame 2700 $ à
monsieur bédard et évoque un problème de
compteurs croisés qu'est-ce que 50 ans
croisé dans les comptes son service
avant 2012 n'y avait pas de définition
de ce qui était un conte en croisé dans
le cas des compteurs croisés la loi
permet qu'hydro-québec rétro facture un
client sur 36 mois
mais il s'agit plutôt d'une erreur de
facturation la rétrofacturation n'est
que de six mois en l'absence d'une
définition claire de compteurs croisé
daniel bédard refuse de payer la facture
de 2700 $ c'est tout à leur avantage à
ce que tous les erreurs de facturation
fina soient considérés comme des haras
de contrats croisés
hydro-québec a évalué le dossier et nous
on a appliqué ce qu'on comprenait à ce
moment là comme étant la définition d'un
conteur croiser le code compteur croisé
qu'on va voir le plus fréquemment c'est
quand il ya plusieurs conteurs dans un
même édifice et qui a une erreur qui a
été commise nous il ya un compteur qui
va physiquement être relié à une adresse
différente et aucun moyen geprim un
câble électrique qui les a menés jusqu'à
maison de notre voisin pour brancher
dessus tu nous notre interprétation
était que le compteur croisille c'était
plus large que ce qui ne veut pas besoin
d'avoir nécessairement de croisement
physique entre le compteur en décembre
dernier
la régie de l'énergie a donné raison à
daniel bédard c'est une erreur de
facturation
mais récemment hydro-québec a précisé
les quatre contes en croiser dans les
conditions de service qui l'encadrent et
les cas comme celui de daniel bédard
seront désormais considérées des comptes
a croisé la facture sera donc plus à
l'est ici nancy desjardins radio canada
montréal